all right it is the time of the week
where we get to hate reott mail a
professional interpretive reading of the
hatred mail that I receive quick
reminder about hatred mail because if
you aren't pro-life you deserve the
death penalty Patriot mail written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom all right a
lot in this one many allegations let's
take a listen to it together neoliberal
shill David Park man admits he's an
accomplice of Donald J Trump David Park
man is a shill for the New World Order
Illuminati Luciferian cabal that is
doing everything in its power to destroy
the United States amy robach knows that
Epstein was murdered David Park man lies
about pizza gate as he knows it's real
David Park man you corporate shill can't
wait until you go through with quitting
YouTube yeah you know this neoliberal
thing just let's assume it's not a troll
and you really think that I've become
some kind of right winger check out over
the last 10 years on the show every few
years I will do a bunch of different
political compass type tests and every
time I do it I have actually moved to
the left I am more left today than I
have ever been before in my life now as
far as you know lied about pizza gate
quitting YouTube stuff like that I don't
know what you're talking about but if
you really want to do the homework and
see have I become more conservative or
or more left over the years the data is
out there my friend check it out
remember that you can use the coupon
code hate reott 42 save 40% off of any
membership at join pakman.com the coupon
code is H 80 r IOT for 0 you save 40%
the hatreds cry ever I've seen them do
it every time that that coupon code is
used on my website what if you could
read 10 books in just one sitting that's
exactly what one of my favorite apps
lets you do it's called bling
and what they do is take thousands of
popular nonfiction books they condense
them down into text or audio that you
can consume in 15 minutes blinka snakes
sure that you're getting all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for there's
a full book you're thinking about buying
you can use blink Asst to get a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself by being able to soak up an
entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes
I recently checked out the book podcast
marketing strategy by Daniel rolls and
Ciaran Rogers and so useful so
particularly applicable to what I'm
doing really recommended blink East has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about 8 bucks a month and you get the
entire library but you can try it
totally free and get 25% off a
subscription when you go to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video